[Music]
foreign
all good thank you for joining me on 20
minute leaders how are you
i'm good how are you great so it's only
so you know
you're one of the most fascinating
people that i get to speak to because
you're helping so many different
non-profits on so many different sectors
and you have such a unique background
coming into this
but first i have to ask your last name
is all good
and you are you're helping so many
non-profits and you're running
collaboration for good is that a
coincidence
i frequently get asked that in in
some ways yes and then in other ways
people say that potentially the name
my name help shaped what i'm doing in
the world like
yeah interesting interesting well
okay so let's you know let's just dive
into it tell me a little bit about
the non-profit world and you know
most people have no idea what nonprofits
are so 501
3cs or is it 51c3 i don't even know
myself
it's basically almost anything in the
501c
category but most people just think of
the 501c3s
uh 501c3s are charitable organizations
but there are about
26 classifications of nonprofits
okay and and so what is a non-profit and
how does it differ from a for-profit
company well the biggest distinction is
basically a non-profit is pretty much
just a corporation
a non-stop corporation that
makes a pledge that any profits
that it generates goes back into the
organization
and to help provide for the services
that the organization
provides so the primary distinct
distinction is really just based around
profit
to be perfectly honest it's like um
for-profits get to pay out their profits
either in stock options
or to family members or whatever
sure they don't have to retain those
profits in
internally and non-profits basically
reinvest
profits back into the social good that
they're doing
sure so so but so people still get a
salary you still have the same id you
have a board c you have board seats you
have
milestones deadlines you're running as a
legitimate company
but the key difference is then how do
you pay off do you pay off dividends
or do you or do you just pull all that
money back into the service that the
company is providing right
yeah for the most part so yeah so
typically speaking you're running for
the most part the same as a typical
business
with some some hindrances i would say
in that process and more so from what
people
think a non-profit is versus what a
non-profit
can be in terms of doing that um but
generally speaking
it's pretty much just a business
with a dual bottom line or sometimes
triple bottom lines or even more so than
that like so the
the primary bottom line for a non-profit
is the social impact or the social
services
that they're trying to accomplish or
make
um in that whereas the primary bottom
line for most businesses
is cash okay that makes a lot of sense
so then comes all good into the picture
and you're
really making an impact on a lot of
nonprofits so what do you do there
so with collaboration for good we
basically
do capacity building programs for
non-profit
organizations in the social good sector
as a
whole um so that's one side of it and
then the other side
of it is is that we basically find and
grow
um social entrepreneurs so people who
will start either
non-profits for-profits or crop
cooperatives but
they're all wanting to take on at least
a double bottom
bottom line so they want to impact their
do a social impact for their communities
that they're targeting
as well as make livable incomes for
themselves in
their employees okay and but and how
does that actually come to play so
fine there's a so there's an interesting
social entrepreneur that that
was trying to get stuff off the ground
how's your
what does your relationship with them
look like uh so
again our primary relationship looks
like um
we run a social good accelerator it's
just called the social good accelerator
um and we work with like 25
social enterprises per year
um with that and so they can be from
zero
to about three to five years in terms of
development
for that so some people are really just
coming in with a strong
idea that we think is viable and that we
think would make a difference
um and other people have been working at
it for three or five years but haven't
gotten
much traction right in that and so then
we help them focus
we help them prioritize what steps they
want to do next so that they can start
actually seeing it more as a sequence of
steps
a messy sequence of steps but still way
forward
um and then we just provide support
community access to um
resources like consultants mentors
peer-to-peer
help and on things like that and we're
moving to a place where eventually we
will also be able to give them
um financial some types of financial
resources as well
so that might be yeah
so and how you know i went through some
accelerators myself and a lot of my
friends who go through startup
accelerators
and you know 500 startups the junction
tech stars etc etc
how does how do these accelerators
differ
from the social accelerator uh
or they so the one that you're running
because you're not focused on
fundraising right
and and you're not necessarily focusing
on on a lot of the for-profit ideas but
so what do you focus on well we actually
the overlap between regular accelerators
is fairly strong i would say there's
something like
a 60 to 75 percent overlap for
the main components of it basically
discovery of who you want and who fits
your
your model for your accelerator right
the class work and things like that that
we're doing i think where we
predominantly differ
from that is is that um
we also have the component of the impact
that we want to make
so wage wealth equity is a big
issue for us so we don't want
um especially since we're targeting
predominantly women and minor
people of color in in our programs is
that we don't
want them to end up in the same
dire strait as they're running a
non-profit or
business that they started and so we're
teaching them about
what's being consistent pay
to well paid right and and so
we try to teach them about like kind of
minimal levels of
income that they want to generate
especially if they're women
um we're talking about like stuff like
you shouldn't be paying yourself
less than 75 a year
um for that i mean and you can do less
but like
your rate should at the very least be 75
and you're just paying yourself a
percentage
of that as opposed to you know so tell
me
so why is that why is that a
recommendation why why do you reckon
because
a lot of other accelerators are telling
their founders you know what i don't
want you to get
maybe you shouldn't take a salary really
for the next two years
that shows a vote of confidence so talk
to me a little bit about the 75
000 yeah so it's basically because
we're focusing on the fact that it's
something that all of our
participants are going to have to try to
achieve
in the first place but we don't but like
a lot of people
who are doing social good are used to
people telling them that they shouldn't
get paid for doing good
right and yeah because then you feel bad
about it i'm getting paid for doing good
yeah i mean and so a lot of people who
work for non-profits or who start
non-profits
end up in situations where they're in
sometimes worse financial shape than the
people that they're providing services
to
the number of people that we know that i
know and that we've worked with in
non-profits
who have to go to local food banks or
personal essentially
pants essential pantries to kind of
get them through the rest of the month
off the income
that they're making is is relatively
high right
and we're trying to stop that um but
also 75 000
i think is that point where most people
can
relax a little bit you're not really
wealthy at that point
but you're not worried that
you might lose everything within two
months okay
sure um and for women i think that's
even more important because
especially if you're a heterosexual
woman one accidental pregnancy and
you're raising
a child that can literally just child
care
alone can run between 15 to 20 000 a
year
and then you still have a child and you
have the health care
yeah that basically just drops a 75 000
salary below 50 sometimes closer back to
35.
um you know on thousand dollars there
and that's just something that we don't
want to see
what what's another recommendation that
you're that you're pushing for
oh it's fascinating yeah so i mean so
not only like paying themselves well
but also paying the people they employ
yeah well and so it's about kind of
changing the dynamic
of what do we consider livable wage
and getting out of that argument of
minimum wage or i'm doing a dollar above
minimum wage which is still just nothing
right minimum wage yeah it's still
pretty much minimum wage and then in
some places like that are
slightly more progressive like madison
like they're they'll argue
for minimum wage of 15 an hour but
the cost of living here is
just to make ends meet you need an
income
of 35 000 or higher probably closer to
40.
and that's just to make ends meet that's
still putting you
in the range that if one crisis happens
you could be out on the street within
like 30 days
you know i was in an economics class at
stanford the other day and the end uh
this really troubling fact this
struggling statistic where
and more than half of americans if they
face an emergency situation where they
have to provide four hundred dollars
cash they're not able to do so right
which i think is something to really
ponder on yeah i mean it's
i mean and that's for a variety of
reasons but a lot of it is also just
because especially with people who work
in the social good sector which isn't
just entirely non-profits
but for a lot of them yeah they have no
cash savings whatsoever they're
definitely
still in that mode where if you grew up
in poverty there was like the mode of
are we playing the telephone this month
or like the heat
this month right and a lot of people who
work in the social good
sector that's kind of where they're at
continuously
so they so during the day they go and
they help others and they
help run social good projects but then
at night they have to decide whether
they're paying their phone bill or the
heater
that's just uh that's that's
unbelievable and i don't think that
that's something that people
often think about on from the aspect of
the people that are actually running
these these projects
tell me a little bit about yourself uh
how did you even get to this
i it doesn't seem very ordinary that
somebody just wakes up and says yeah i'm
going to run an accelerator for social
goods
for social good companies and i'm gonna
be and i'm gonna help social
entrepreneurs
and make an impact on the world so how
do you even get there
well mine was a bit of a windy path um
my first job was with a non-profit when
i was 14 years old and so
i actually come from a history of
poverty um
uh we li i was raised in warren ohio it
was a steel belt
town um basically and um
the steel industry died uh
during like that period of time and so
it went from like a
pretty middle-class town to a town that
had really
great divides in it and so
i mean because most people either went
into the military or they went into the
steel mill
um for it so um
we went from kind of being middle class
to being ex
poor and then my father died and then we
went to being extremely poor
um uh for that we were a family of six
at that point and i would assume that
my mom was barely making twenty thousand
dollars
wow um for us so
at 14 i got my first job and it was
twofold to help out around the house and
um an actual financial way but
also just because my mom used to just
dress me really girly and i hated all of
the clothes that she would buy me
and so i agreed to take on purchasing my
own school clothes
if she let me get a job amazing
so um and i started working
with a few non-profits then but i think
that's
when i still really started um
consolidating my thoughts around
community and our responsibility
to society so as a country as a city
as just an even a neighborhood what is
your responsibility to the people
that are around you i didn't want to go
into the army but i wasn't opposed to
military service
so in junior high i
participated in a program that led me to
[Music]
a junior air force rotc program
and i basically made a decision that i
could
still do military service and get a
college education
which was kind of looked down upon in
our family like a
college education it was kind of like
you need to go to work as quickly as
possible
and start making a living for for
yourself
there um i got the
full ride scholarship from the air force
to do chemical engineering
wow at penn state and chemical
engineering was the air force's choice i
was actually more interested in
mechanical
engineering at the time but it was the
option that was going to
get me the scholarship with a lot less
competition so
i was like fine i can do chemical
engineering
wow but then when i went to penn state i
also made sure that i had a second
um degree option which was called the
administration of justice
which is kind of a combination between
um
looking at society and its
infrastructure
and the um criminology and crime and
laws and crimes basically and um
for that and um so i was doing that
for most of college and then i came out
as a lesbian um which i should have
probably thought of
earlier when i basically took over
purchasing my own clothes but i did
um and um
that was before don't ask don't tell and
so i did lose my scholarship
um or that and um you lost the
scholarship
yeah because at that point the military
didn't accept out
and so so at what point in your college
career
does that happen that was like the
end of the sophomore beginning of the
junior year
all of a sudden you get a letter and
you're saying listen and never mind
please don't
come to the military by the way we also
want you to pay
for the two years that you've done and
the two more years that you have in
front of you
uh yes and no so that was is what
typically would have happened
but my officers the officers i worked
with
really liked me um and i was actually
on road on the path to
enter the air force as like um
a first lieutenant with just being a
borrower
a bar you know just being a little bit
away from being a captain
wow when they pre-informed me that i was
going to lose the scholarship
and they submitted multiple letters of
recommendation that i
i not have to repay oh okay
stuff before so then it just became a
matter of
i had to pay for the future years
right of college which was highly
expensive
because i was yeah that are still
considered out of state
and i was also supporting my mother and
my younger brother
and so that actually what it did is
because
of the notice change i became
essentially
homeless and penalty penniless for a
while
even though i was working full time
almost all the money
that i was working full time for was
going back to my mom and my brother
and one of my nieces that was living
with my mom
and but i don't want to say it was a
it wasn't like your typical homelessness
like it was
it was kind of a privileged homelessness
if you could say that
i was on a couch there was there was i
knew
i wasn't going to stay homeless it was
more just about
how long would it take me to accumulate
the money that i could then live
somewhere
what does that practically mean homeless
on a college campus
well it means that there's one like
there's hidden places that you can sleep
in on college
wow i mean because like just think about
like when you're on a college campus and
you're doing
all nighter at the library right people
fall asleep there but
you don't actually get to lay down and
go to sleep you
you have to like pretend that you're
studying and you put a book out and you
lay your head
so just to get this right you would go
to classes all day you would work
to support your family back at home and
then you would go and find hidden spots
at a university so that you can get some
rest in order to wake up for classes and
work the next day
yes and how long did that last for
uh that lasted for about six and six and
a half months
definitely it's much yeah
a lot longer time than it should have if
i wasn't taking care
of like my family because it basically
became i could take this money
accumulate like a month of rent and then
the current month
of rent for a deposit um sure
or i can basically keep sending the
money
to my family and then i'm saving a much
larger
much smaller amount like month basically
right no no of course no that's
unbelievable you know the i'm
i'm just i'm so inspired by the work
that you're doing and
and you know the adversity that you that
you went through and
i'm sure that it shines with every
entrepreneur social entrepreneur that
you get to work with
and i hope that we get to work together
on some projects later on as well
and i have to come see this accelerator
myself and because it just sounds so
very cool
and i do have to ask before we leave and
i can't believe 20 minutes are almost
over i have so many more questions
i have to ask you the last question
which is three words
that you would best describe yourself
um i would say i'm
i'm fairly resilient i think um across
the board i would say so
um kind of quiet or
potentially composed generally speaking
i try not to let
too much anger me unreasonably
um i do try to keep a certain amount of
anger
there if it actually can help propel
things forward
nice and then i would say i'm
curious but i would say more people
would probably call that querying
then curious because my friends hate it
i'm always asking questions
about about stuff and like sometimes
they're like i know what i'm talking
about and i'm like well
it's not that i don't trust that you
know what you're talking about i'm
asking questions so i can figure out
how this relates to other things i love
it i love it
i love it i'm lisa thank you so so much
keep on helping people change the world
keep on changing the world yourself this
is a
such a unique privilege for me to have
done this and then i look forward to
remaining in touch
okay thank you and thanks for the the
ask in the invite
of course thank you bye